Camille is in Atlanta hi Camille welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi babe are you
doing better than I deserve what's up
good my student loan
well my privacy loans are default right
now and they are offering you a
settlement at forty one forty eight
thousand which is not what I have I
actually feel like a good number to give
them back is about twenty thousand we're
from fifteen to twenty thousand I still
don't have that so my question sees is
my room and I was in long-term roommates
we're looking to to purchase a home next
year I keep going up here and I make
about 90 K so I have I have a lot of
money I paid out most of my best ones
left other loans and so my question is
if I purchase a home of her do you think
it's a good idea to go into purchases
home with the idea of paying it off
though once we sell it no it is not a
good idea to purchase a home with a
roommate absolutely not what not because
everything that can go wrong will we
call them the DS you're forming a
partnership divorced default drug use
disinterest disability death any of
those things occur the other one of you
is screwed because you're attached at
the hip with handcuffs called a home
mortgage and there's no easy way to get
out of that very very bad idea to buy a
house with somebody you're not married
to so no I would not recommend that and
you don't need to buy a house anyway
you've got the student loan debt you got
to clean up oh my get the 20 K why would
you be buying a house if you're too
broke to clean up your debt yeah my my
goal was the make the parts of the house
and then in five years Feli hopes and
then with the with the prayer that it it
makes me money yeah that's that's a good
way to live money and to be in a house
when you're broke
so now let's let's get the things in the
right order the right order is we need
to clear up our debts build an emergency
fund and save a down payment you make
ninety thousand dollars a year you can
afford a house when you've gotten your
debts
cleared and so what is the balance on
this private student loan the total
balance of they say you owe total not
what they're offering at the moment
because I'm in the forgiveness of the
the interest rate program or whatever
and it's in collections but anyway it's
96 thousand and their armor I would
settle that for 48 more debt no and it's
a private student loan it's not a
federally insured student loan right
these are the private people no the
Federals are about the same amount but I
just haven't gotten around to figuring
out what's the best you have another
90,000 and student loan debt that's
federal as well by this time the
thousand in addition to the private
right what is your degree in sociology
sociology and you spent 200 grand it
with all the interest and everything in
a year's worth of graduate school yes
Wow okay well the good news is you're
making 90 so that that's just gonna take
you a while to clean this up
you need to rent as cheaply as you can
possibly rent get all these nice rice
and beans and I might one of my very
first goals how much do you owe on your
car 80 m38 thousand I'm gonna be paying
that off in the next six months okay I
want you to list all of your debts
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything but the little one attack
the little one when you get to a 25
thousand dollar number on that debt
snowball you save up twenty five
thousand and you offer it to the private
student loan as if you can clear them
you're not going to get settlements on
the federal the Federals that federally
insured do not settle they will waive
some late fees sometimes they'll waive
some interest and other miscellaneous
collections charges but but they will
not waive the principal because it's
federally insured the federal government
is going to give them the principal if
you don't so they do not settle on that
part but yeah you need to clean up you
got a lot you got ways to go here I mean
you made a pretty good-sized mess
and so get your car paid off let's work
through the private student loans work
through the federally insured student
loans and this is gonna take you a few
years you need to rent something as
cheap as possible you definitely do not
need to buy and you for sure
don't need to buy with a partner with a
roommate Danger Danger Danger don't do
it I hope I talked you out of that I'm
know if I did or not